So welcome, everyone.
Thank you for
coming to this talk.
My name is Etienne.
I'm from Montreal.
I'm an Android GDE, an
Android GDG organizer,
so I like a lot of
Android related things
as you can guess.
And I'm actually pretty
passionate about VR.
So this story
started when we went
to a hack-a-thon in San
Francisco after I/O for VR
at the Adobe offices.
You have to play
around with Tango
and different-- there were these
dive helmets for the Tango.
It was quite fascinating.
So I started basically
thinking, well,
I have to start making
apps for this thing.
This is interesting.
I want to make
apps for Cardboard,
greater coverage for people.
Thing is, when you start
making Cardboard app--
and I wanted to do it
with Java because I
like challenges that way--
I had a lot to learn.
I didn't actually know all
that much about OpenGL.
I mucked about with
it ever since the '90s
but it kept changing.
I'm a bit lost with
what was going on,
so things kept breaking every
time I changed a small detail.
So that was really painful.
So, not being a very
sensible person,
I've been doing
this since last May
and I'd like to share with you
some of the things I found out
and some of the pitfalls
you could possibly avoid.
All right, so I have
a few sections here.
So this one's about
OpenGL theory.
So to be aware of
the ecosystem, you
have OpenGL-- which
is for desktops--
and you have something
called OpenGL ES-- which
is for mobile.
Out there right now, OpenGL
ES 1 is sort of non-existent
anymore.
It's what you have on the
first versions of the devices.
They had a
non-programmable pipeline.
So I'm going to be saying
programmable pipeline a lot
during this talk,
just fair warning.
With ES 2, it brought
the programmable pipeline
to the mobile world and
this was a good thing.
So now we're in
2005-- 2015, thank
you-- and we have OpenGL
ES 3.1 and something called
the Android Extension Packs.
So these add a ton of features.
So you get compute
shaders, tensile textures,
accelerated visual effect,
high quality ETC2/EAC texture
compression, advanced texture
rendering, standardized picture
size, render buffer formats,
more and more and more.
And the Android
Extension Packs allow
us to do things like this when
you're looking at an Android
device such as Android
TVs, which might be running
very powerful hardware.
So these extension packs, you
install on a specific device
and if the device's
hardware supports it,
you get almost desktop
equivalent performance.
So this was introduced at
I/O-- I think 2014, actually,
and it's based on the
the Unreal Engine 5.
And for the future we're going
to have something coming up
called Vulkan.
So, Vulkan was
announced this summer.
It's a new initiative.
If you've heard of Apple's Metal
for iOS, it's fairly similar.
So the idea is that you're
even closer to the GPU.
They strip away parts
of the framework
that would make things
theoretically easier for you.
This will likely lead
to more complex apps,
but for developers, it will
give them far greater control.
So, we still have to see
a bit more about that.
It's just been announced.
I haven't seen any
specs yet, so I
think it's being
worked on currently
at various manufacture
offices and things like that.
So, you might be a bit dizzy
at this point because of all
the alphabet soup and acronyms
I've been throwing around,
and that is normal.
The key take aways
from the previous slide
are, plain OpenGLs for desktop.
ES is for mobile devices.
ES 2 is where you
started getting
the programmable pipeline.
ES 3.1 is what we'll
be looking at today.
Things to keep in mind-- it's
supported on the Nexus 5.
It's supported since
Lollipop, but some phones
won't support it due to limited
hardware on these phones.
So You're going to need
to programmatically check
if you get into a
production kind of scenario.
So let's look at
core OpenGL concepts
we're going to be playing
around with today.
So, we're going to go for
a minimum effective dose.
I'm going to try to gloss
over a lot of stuff,
because we only have
so much time and time
is precious, right?
So we're going to look at my
geometry, math, and core 3D
concepts, and my idea is
that not a lot of people
here in the audience have a
lot of previous experience
with OpenGL.
So I'm actually going
to ask this right now.
Who here has actually wrote
an app using OpenGL ES 2 or 3?
Right, so a few people.
Good.
Share notes with the others
if they look confused.
So, our core concepts.
We're going to be
talking about 3D space.
You're probably familiar with
the idea of Euclidean space,
right?
x, y, and z.
I had the honor of choosing
a graph where the axes are
sort of long for OpenGL.
So, just to clarify something,
on OpenGL this is x, this is y,
and z is depth.
Then we're going to be talking
about the vertex a lot,
or something called
vertices, plural.
The thing to note though,
which might be a bit confusing,
is that we're going to be
talking of the vertex of course
as points in, say, an object--
as part of like a triangle that
composes the faces of the object
that we're going to render.
But we're also going to be
talking about attributes
hooked to that vertex.
So it's not like
the pure math vertex
that we're used to talk about.
It will have other concepts
associated to it, like normals,
color-- things like that.
So, vertices assemble
into primitives.
This is like the
old school graph
from the OpenGL Red Book from
the '90s, or even earlier
probably.
The one we're going to
be playing with a lot
is triangles.
To make a distinction between
triangles and triangle strips
or fans or all
these other things,
you might be wondering, why
is this even in the spec?
And just a quick-- we're
going to be talking
about performance a little bit.
One of the things with
OpenGL is that the more data
you have to shove into the
pipeline, the slower it gets.
So you might notice here that
a triangle strip, for example,
uses up less vertices than the
plain old series of triangles
because they share vertices.
So, let's talk about models.
So, these are wire frame models.
As probably a lot of you know,
models are actually usually--
well in this case, we're
going to talk about triangles
as our primitives,
so all these models
will be composed of
vertices that form
triangles that form the model.
The important point I want
to make with this slide
is that when you
create a model, say
we are going to
talk about a cube,
the coordinates of
the vertices are
going to be around
the 0, 0, 0-- origin.
So everything is
always going to be
relative to the origin,
more for management reasons
as we'll see a bit later.
So, another concept you
have to get your head around
is transforms.
So, we're talking about
translations-- moving
an object in a different
point in space,
rotations-- twisting
an object, and scaling
is also one-- making
things bigger or smaller.
What you might want to
note from this slide
is that the order that you
apply operations is important.
The good news here is
that the example code
that comes with
the talk, all this
has been taken care of for you.
You don't have to
experiment and go, "oh,
why is this moving all around
so wrong and I'm confused."
So a lot of that
will be taken away,
which is good when you
want to experiment.
Just keep that in mind.
You're going to get a bit
deeper into the rabbit hole.
All right, linear algebra.
Transforms imply matrices,
multiplication of matrices.
So most people, their math
courses are far, far away
and these are fuzzy
concepts, and you
don't want to mess around
too much with that.
The good news is
that this is all
taken care of, mostly by DSDKs
and APIs, so we don't need
to worry too much about it.
You do need to understand
that all the operations I've
talked about usually
end up in one big matrix
and you multiply your
vertex by that matrix,
and the vertex will be placed
into its proper space--
its proper coordinate space.
We'll come back to that.
All right, another big concept.
So, projections and cameras.
So, when we're going to
configure our OpenGL pipeline,
we're going to have to set
up rules of projection.
So if you look at
the first figure,
the idea here is we're telling
GL how to project things.
So it involves telling it what
are the bounds of our view--
the top, the bottom,
left, and right--
and also involves giving
it some configuration
so it kind of knows what
is far and what is close.
So when it comes time
to project the vertices,
we have a 3D space onto our
2D screen, or our 2D rendering
area, it'll know how to
proportion these things.
So this is through configuring.
That, again, don't get
too worried about it.
You'll see that line of code.
You probably won't
even notice it.
It's a one liner, but it's
a fairly simple thing.
But you need to be aware of all
this theory, fix things when
they start going wrong.
The other diagram is just here
to illustrate that we also
need to place our
models, but we also
need to put the camera in there.
So we have the concept of
objects in space projected
onto a screen, but we
also have the concept
of this camera that's moving
about and looking at things.
So that's also an important
thing to remember,
because that's going to be
another mathematical operation
that we're going to
shovel under the carpet,
but that's going to be
there and that you'll
want to be aware of.
So, lighting.
Lighting is super exciting.
So we'll learn how to implement
Lambertian reflectance.
Lambertian reflectance is named
after Johann Heinrich Lambert,
who introduced the concept
of perfect diffusion
in his 1760 book, "Photometria."
I actually have a few scans
from an early edition.
Yeah, all right.
Let's start that over.
My only attempt at a joke today.
Simple lighting, right?
We want to keep things simple
and lighting, to be sure,
is actually a super
important subject in OpenGL
and it gets gnarly very quickly.
So we want to avoid
that for today.
We just want to have the base
minimum lighting model that we
can use to start experimenting.
So we do need to understand
two concepts again.
Ambient lighting, which is
just the light that reaches
an object after bouncing
around everywhere in the room.
So it's your background
radiation lighting.
It's the minimum amount of light
that a point on the surface
is going to get by
default. And then
you have something
called diffuse lighting
we'll be playing with,
which is the light that
reaches your eye after a source
of light-- the rays bounce off
a surface and reach your eye.
So here the amount of
light reaching your eye
will be directly
proportional to the angle
between the surface of the
object and the source of light.
And that's what this
whole Lambert cosine
law is going to be
about, which we're
going to see on a few frames.
But, again, very easy
to calculate all that
stuff with OpenGL.
Right now I'm
giving you context,
so when you see that line of
code, you'll be like, oh yeah,
it's that thing he
talked about earlier.
Another important concept
related to the lighting
is normals.
So a normal is a
perpendicular vector
pointing straight out of a
face or of a facet of a shape.
But in our case,
we're going to have
normals associated to vertices.
And that's slightly
different, because if you
look at the last diagram
here, we are seeing normals
coming out of a bent shape.
So what happens is that
you can make approximations
with normals where,
even if you are actually
playing with a triangle, that
triangle is part of a sphere.
You can make it so that the
normals are pointing out
from the center of the sphere,
so that helps the lighting
model light this thing
as if it was a sphere
and help you get the better
simulation of these shapes.
So the other thing I
want to quickly say
is that normals-- you might
all know this already--
but it's worth mentioning that
normals are called normals
because they are normalized
vectors, meaning that they have
one unit lengths.
You might remember that from
your old-- or in my case--
old math courses.
So, just to make a
little reference.
All right, so, we've
talked about vertices
and how in OpenGL
they are actually
a combination of things.
So, in this case, I just
wanted to show quickly
that you have-- basically
we're going to have position,
the normal, the color.
And texture we're not going
to play around with today,
but these are all
attributes that
are hooked up with this
bundle of data that
is a vertex in our pipeline.
And on the right
side, I just wanted
to point out and give you a hint
that if you've never done GLSL
before, how that
language looks like.
GLSL stands for Graphic
Language Shading-- no, wait.
GL Shading Language, which
is kind of redundant.
Maybe it's Graphical Library
Shading Language, rather,
so it's not redundant at all.
So just be aware of the
vec3, vec4, and vec2.
That really represents an
area of floats in this case,
all right?
Just so you know.
One of the few
last, complicated,
gnarly diagrams I'm
going to show today.
I'm not actually
going to go over this.
Just wanted to point out if
you go to the khronos site,
you can get the
full picture of what
is the OpenGL pipeline
in big detail for 3.1.
It's actually good reading
once you've gotten familiar
with the basic
concepts and you want
to start playing around
configuring your own set up.
But let's skip over
that right now and look
at a very high level view.
You can think of
the OpenGL pipeline
as a client server relationship,
a very simple one at that.
You have your application,
which is running off of the CPU,
talking to the OpenGL ES
framework client, which is also
running off of the CPU.
And you're talking to this to
configure this whole pipeline.
You're going to be
feeding data in there,
and that's all
happening in the CPU
and CPU land is kind
of slow, and a transfer
from CPU land to GPU land is
almost equivalent to a web
call.
That's really the key
idea of this slide
that you should take away.
The other thing is I had
to have a perfmatter slide.
It has nothing to do
with the [INAUDIBLE].
I couldn't find a way
to shove it in there.
But this magic number,
0.016 milliseconds
in this case, if
you're rendering
goes over that, you're going
to make your users nauseous.
Especially since we're not
talking about the Vive here.
We're talking about
Cardboard on phones, which
might not be all that great.
So you're going to need to
start thinking about performance
pretty early in the process.
So the better way of doing
this, and you'll see it--
we have it in our examples-- is
to have a frame rate indicator
that you can keep an eye on so
that when you're experimenting,
if ever you see that frame
rate drop dramatically--
under 60 frames a second--
which you can't go over anyway,
because the refresh rate of the
device is pretty much 60 frames
a second.
But when you start
dropping those frames,
you have to ask yourself, OK,
I should start being careful.
I should probably
change my approach,
read a few optimization
articles, and start fixing it.
So, early optimization I'm not
super fond of-- as most people
aren't-- but early warning
signs, that's pretty good.
So the simplified graph
for the OpenGL pipeline.
The thing to know
here-- the color code.
So the blue is mostly
happening in user space.
It's happening in
your app in Java.
So that's where you're going
to take all these vertices
that you got from somewhere and
shove them into the pipeline.
That's where you're going
to configure the pipeline
and actually pass
it the programs
that it's going to execute
at different steps.
This is where most of the Java
code you're doing is happening.
After that, the
vertex step is one
of the first programmable
stages that you're
going to give a program to
the pipeline to execute.
This thing is running over
each of the vertices being
fed into the pipeline.
I know it's very
theoretical right now,
but hopefully it will
start coming together
in a few slides.
I just want to get good basics.
So those vertices, you're
going to be calculating on them
and you're going to be
basically projecting them
onto the screen, which will
allow then the green part--
so the yellow parts are
programmable stages.
Green part are fixed stages.
You don't get to program them.
They're part of the
OpenGL framework.
And in this case,
what's going to happen
is it's going to
take the vertex data
and it's going to decide,
OK, so where on screen
are these primitives?
So it's going to map those
out, and once this is known,
it goes on to the
fragment stage--
the other programmable stage.
Fragments are
basically programs that
are there to paint a pixel.
So, for each of the
pixels you have on screen,
the fragment shader's
going to run once.
So we'll see how we can do a lot
of fun stuff with that later.
Finish up the chain,
the frame buffer.
It's just there to
give you the hint
that you can make a lot more
complex builds with the OpenGL
pipeline, but you don't need to.
You can basically see these two
steps and up to the GL surface
view as I'm dumping a
bitmap to the screen.
This slide is to reinforce
the idea-- which I don't find
is very intuitive
for most people--
that you first have vertices
that are being computed on,
which are projected
onto a screen.
And once that relationship
between the model and space
and the actual screen is done,
then each of these pixels--
the system knows which
shape they belong to.
So it now knows what
computations to accomplish
and what parameters to
pass to your program
for it to calculate the
color of that pixel.
The smallest light on the
power of parallel processing.
So what we're
looking at here is--
I couldn't find a good
video of it, sadly.
It's an NVIDIA event where
the MythBusters where there
to actually show why
is parallel processing
much more awesome than
linear processing or a CPU.
So all they had set
up is a paintball gun
that was drawing the Mona Lisa.
So they had the first
one instance at a time.
The robot arm would paint a
wall with paintball pellets,
which was kind of cool.
And then they had a massive
array representing GPUs.
A lot of them, running on
NVIDIA hardware-- presumably--
painting a picture
really quickly.
So that's the other thing
to think about is that,
if that if program is running
for each and every pixel
in your frame, it's
actually all running
in parallel, which is how this
can be actually a fast process.
OK, so some practice.
Some actual code.
Get ready.
It's going to be heavy.
Maybe not that
much, but, anyway.
We're going to start with
vanilla Android OpenGL.
So again, we have a few
people who played around
with at least OpenGL, so you're
going to be familiar with this.
I'm going to sell the
punchline a little bit.
You'll see that
with Cardboard, you
don't need to add that much
code to what you've already
learned to actually get
the VR app running, which
is the good news.
So this class diagram, the
takeaway here-- GLSurfaceView
is an actual view.
It inherits from the view.
And the thing that
actually draws to that view
is a renderer.
So that's a subclass
of GLSurfaceView.
You are the person that
will implement that.
That's more of an interface
or an abstract class.
I'm not sure, I
should've checked.
I will for the next talk.
But basically you're going to be
implementing onSurfaceCreated,
onSurfaceChange maybe--
most of the time mine
is empty-- and onDrawFrame.
So the action all happens in the
surface created and draw frame.
Surface created to initialize
this whole big pipeline
we've been talking about.
Draw a frame just to
take the data that
needs to be in the pipeline
for now, shove it down there,
press draw, we're done.
All right.
Threading-- quick
note on threading.
I made this nice,
little diagram,
and I want to really go
quickly over it though.
It's on its own render thread.
The renderer is running
on its own render thread.
It's got its own dedicated
GL rendering thread.
So you have the same
kind of challenges
that you have with
the UI thread.
If you want to communicate
with your renderer,
you need to go through something
like queueEventRunnable
or some other
threading mechanism.
OK?
And this is so that you can
get reliable draw calls and all
your 60 frames per second.
Cardboard SDK.
I promised it wouldn't be
much more difficult. It's not.
There are, however,
a few new methods and
in the stereo renderer, which is
the equivalent of the renderer
we just looked at.
So you have a few more
calls that come into play
when Cardboard is there,
and we'll see which
those are in a few seconds.
You might notice at the
bottom here that we are still
using jars in the libs folder.
Somebody talk to that team
and get them on grade level,
thank you.
So setting up the GL Pipeline.
The first step that we quickly
glossed over in the renderer.
So onSurfaceCreated is being
called with an EGLConfig.
I'll say it right up front.
This might be called
more than once
during the lifetime
of your program
if you get called in, et cetera.
So we have to be ready to
think about reinitializing
everything.
Now, that being said, here most
of the complexity of the steps
is abstract in a class
I call geometry, which
you can see in my actual
sample code that's
available on my GitHub with a
link at the end of the talk.
I just wanted to give you
the basics so we get started.
So initBuffers.
So that's step one.
Then step two is going
to be in the GL program.
So those yellow steps
in the pipeline,
we're going to configure those
after setting up the buffers.
And then, after we've
set up the programs,
we're going to
initialize handles.
So let's look at
each of those steps
and break down what
they actually do.
Step one, initializing buffers.
This is basically
initializing a chunk of memory
so that we can shove floats in
there that will be our vertices
and our vertex attributes,
all bundled in there
so that we can then
pass it to the pipeline.
So, as you can see, it's
fairly straightforward code.
Not much to say here except
you're almost in C land,
but that's OK.
You're going to have to get
used to it with OpenGL a bit.
It's not that complicated.
So step 2.1, initialize
in the GL program.
I even bothered
putting this here just
to remind you that we're talking
about the yellow stages--
programmable stage
of the pipeline--
to mention that vertex shader
code and fragment shader code
are actually big string blobs.
They're actually
the source code.
That's what we're
passing in there.
We won't dig into the
load shader method
that you see at the
top, because it's
pretty much the same process
as what's happening below here.
So the first thing you
do is, you call GL-- so,
notice they're all
static method calls.
Every time you interact
with the pipeline,
it's that kind of call.
In this case, we're
using GLE ES 30.
You might have been using
20 before or whatever,
so the number changes depending
on features that you're using.
So we're creating a program
and we're getting a handle
to our program.
So we're basically
telling the pipeline,
create a program object for me.
And it's giving us back
the pointer, pretty much.
Then we can take-- we've
used the same kind of process
to create handles to
vertex shader and fragment
shader up top.
So at that point, we
take those two handles
that have been initialized
in the pipeline
and we pass those two
shaders into the program
to finish with a link call.
So the fun part-- and
we'll see that later--
is that when you do this, you're
going to actually get feedback
from OpenGL as to whether or
not you have compile errors,
and they're going
to be a bit verbose.
So that's going to be
interesting in a few slides.
All right, so, step three.
So I've talked
about the handles,
so this is how you get them.
Literally give the string
that's going to be the-- well,
we'll see in the shader that's
the actual variable name.
So it's through a strain.
Might seem a bit clumsy
of a way, but-- Yeah.
All right so, this is our first
shader, the vertex shader.
It's a fairly simple semi
pass-through vertex shader.
So this means that we're
not doing much here
except transforming our current
vertex into its final position,
as I talked about earlier.
So we apply model view and
projection transformations
that are stored in this matrix.
So one matrix can be a
bundle of transformation
that you can apply in one shot.
And that's what
we're doing here.
So that lets us know
where that vertex is
going to end up on screen.
For the fragment
shader, it's going
to come along afterwards
to get its list of pixels.
While we're here, these
are-- we have to mention,
these are the inputs that we
just used in our Java code.
So I just want to
point those out
so you make a direct mental
link between the two.
And the outputs are
kind of important.
And the syntax is actually
slightly different in ES 2
for people who've
done ES 2 before.
Like in and out I don't
believe were in GL ES 2.
So it's good to
know these things,
because your old things might
break if you start doing 3.13.
And then the output
basically are
things that are
going to be passed
on-- varyings that are going
to be passed on to the fragment
shader.
So varyings, well, I won't get
into that concept right now,
but we can talk about it later
if you're interested, maybe
after the talk.
So the last big point
here is that we're
going to set our color--
our vColor-- that's
going to be passed to
the fragment shader to 1.
1, 1, 1, 1, which
means white pixel.
Or rather, white vertex
attribute, I should say.
And then next up
in the pipeline,
as illustrated here,
we have our fragment
shader with the color
being passed into it,
and we see that all it's
doing is taking the color that
was given to it by the vertex
shader and just saying,
OK, that's the code of my pixel.
That's it.
Not doing anything.
That's another
passed-through shader.
All right so, what
does this give us?
So, once the steps
in the pipeline
have executed, following
a call to draw--
I'm calling it simpleDraw
here because it's
more of an example.
So I just wanted to
show you how that works.
So first step, we're
going to use the program.
So if you remember
when we initialized,
that's where we basically
tell OpenGL, OK, those
shaders I've configured,
time to use them now.
Then we pass data
to those shaders.
So we already have our handles.
We have our variables into
which we're pushing the data.
So we're bridging the gap
between the two again.
So we pass our
projection matrix--
or our transform
matrix, sorry-- and then
we also pass vertices and
normals in a big bunch.
And then the last
call here, DrawArrays.
So we're just basically
drawing a number of--
and then we're giving it the
number of vertices in there.
And you might notice that the
first parameter, GL_TRIANGLES,
is us telling OpenGL, so I'm
passing you all these vertices
and their triangles.
It could've been triangle
strip if our information was
configured differently,
but they're not.
We're trying to
keep things simple.
I didn't mention this, but
obviously at the bottom here,
you see the result of this.
It's a white square-- a white
cube, actually, what we're
facing in our demo program.
All right, basic lighting.
So I'm trying to fly
through a lot of this stuff,
so you can come and ask me
questions after if you're
kind of like, uh, he went a bit
fast there, what the hell was
that?
So basic light model--
if we use the shader
as we've configured
them right now,
this is what we're going
to get when we're going
to rotate our cube in space.
Not exactly right.
What we want is
this on the right.
So, we need to have a minimum of
lighting in there for our scene
to do any kind of sense.
And we're not going to go beyond
minimum, because that rabbit
hole is pretty deep--
and pretty awesome--
but we want to get
somewhere today.
So, how do we get to this?
We need a light source.
We're hard coding it
in the shader here,
and you can see that at the
very top-- so the u_LightPos
right there.
But you can also know how
we apply the uMVMatrix here,
not MVP.
So there's an important
little distinction here
that you'll see in
the example code.
It's because you want to
put that light in 3D space,
not projected on screen.
Because you're still working
in the theoretical model so
you want to put all the points
in space at the right place.
So you're taking that light
and you're putting it here,
and you want it to
be moved relative
to the camera, et cetera.
But you don't want it
projected on screen,
because you're still
at the step where
you're going to be
calculating theoretical stuff.
You're not yet in screen space.
So that's why the projection
part is not there.
So, our point light source.
Point light source-- one point
emits rays in all directions.
Transforming the
vertex into eye space.
So, we're applying the
same model view transform
to our vertex and our normal,
because all these three
things with the light
source are going
to used in the calculations to
find out what color we should
be giving our vertex.
Then the way to find that out,
we get a light direction vector
from the light
source to the vertex.
So we find out what
that vertex is-- sorry,
that vector is-- then we
calculate the famous Lambert
factor.
So that's actually
very, very simple.
We just want the angle
between the normal
and the light vectors,
and having that angle
allows us to determine
what kind of shade
we're going to give
to that surface.
The 0.1 at the
bottom, actually--
so the actual finding
out of the angle
is the dot product we see there.
So that dot method, being
called with modelViewNormal
and lightVector, that's the
one that calculates the angle.
And the max part, with the
second parameter being 0.1,
that's the minimum
amount of light that's
going to be on the surface.
I talked about ambient light.
This is ambient light,
and the dot product
is the Lambert factor,
which is diffusion light.
And then we multiply that
with the color of the object.
So far, our object is white.
We multiply it by white.
It's going to give us a
varying factor, and we're done.
All right so,
running that gave us
the screenshot we saw earlier.
So, let's enable the
Cardboard SDK now.
Enough flat 3D.
We're done.
All right, so, very
simple first thing.
This is your layout.
You just want a
full on Cardboard
view that fills out
your whole view space.
Then your main activity-- in
this case, VRTalkActivity.
So, these three lines
highlighted here
are what you need to
actually configure your view.
So you set VRModeEnabled
to whatever.
In this case, I set
it to false just
to show you what happens when
you don't have VR enabled.
You're just seeing a plain,
magic window type thing.
And turning it on just
gives us a stereoview.
At this point,
what's happening is,
we're calling the
draw methods twice
for half the screen with
different camera perspectives--
those two eyes-- and this is
the result. At this point,
we can just slip this in a
Cardboard unit and we're good.
We have stereoscopy.
So, what does this look like?
There's two parts now.
Instead of just having
one draw command,
we have two draw command.
onNewFrame-- well,
it's not at all a draw
command I should say, but it's
being called that every frame.
And the idea here
is that anything
that you wouldn't want to
set up twice for both eyes,
because it's the same for both
eyes, you do that job here.
In this case, if
you remember, we
talked about the
projection cone earlier.
So this is where we set it.
So we do setLookAtM and we pass
all the parameters, so now,
wait.
No, that's not it.
That's the camera position.
Sorry.
Confused things.
Wrong thing.
Anyway, so at this
point, what we're
saying is basically we're
setting up our camera based
on-- well, it is the
projection cone of sorts,
but anyway, you'll
see in a second.
Oh.
Yeah, and before I miss that,
the set light position here
would be a place where you
could set a moving light source,
but we don't actually have
that in our current scene.
But if we wanted our model
to dynamically update,
we could do those
operations here,
because you don't want to run
once for each eye, obviously.
So, the actual onDrawEye
command, where things
get a bit more interesting.
So first thing that's good to
do is just to clear the buffers.
So just basically
clear the screen
so that you don't
see the results
of the previous operation--
the previous frame
being rendered--
having been rendered.
And this is where we set up
our view from our frustrum.
So we find out what the
ratio is for each eye,
just so that our perspective--
we won't get a squished image.
We do that one call
here, and that's
what's going to set up
our whole cone of view.
It's fairly simple.
We define left, right,
bottom, top, near, and far.
So, calculating the
view transform matrix.
This is the part where
we take the camera
position and the eye, basically,
and turn it into a view matrix.
That's why we need both.
So this is the part where you
basically-- the view is camera.
Think of "v"-- the vMatrix
as the camera matrix.
So at that point, we have
our projection matrix,
we have our camera matrix.
We know the heighth and
width of our viewport,
so geometry, for reasons
of its own, uses that.
Don't pay too much
attention to it.
The important parts
are the updating
of information coming
from the renderer
so that you can draw stuff
based on the dynamically
changing position of
the head of the user.
And then the draw
command at the bottom.
So we'll get back to what
actually happens in the draw
command a bit later.
So, this is the
part where things
get a little bit more exciting.
So what's the point of all this?
At which point am I
starting to experiment
and having fun,
because, to be honest,
the part I'm talking about-- all
this is-- it's the boring bit.
You want to see things
animate on screen.
You want to create a world.
You want to be creative
and fast and active
and you want to do stuff.
You just don't want
to poke around.
So the problem that we
have is that-- well, OK.
I'll talk about live coding.
So we want to set up an
environment for live coding.
What is live coding?
It's not like live coding on
stage-- not today, I'm sorry.
With Wi-Fi and
everything-- and you'll see
I need the Wi-Fi
for my little demo--
that would not have
been a great idea.
Live coding is when
you have a code,
build, run cycle that is so fast
it's basically instantaneous,
so that you get instant response
as you type out your program.
You see what's happening.
So this is basically a
fragment shader editor online.
So we're basically live
editing the shader.
You see as I comment out
stuff, we can see it in action.
So here we're just basically
varying the amount of color,
depending on our x and our
y on a simple sine wave.
So just poking about
very, very quickly, we
can experiment and find
out how all of this works
and get a very good
feeling for-- oh,
so that's what a shader--
a fragment shader does--
and you can come up with ideas.
So, that instant feedback
loop is super important,
and on Android everybody's
painfully aware
than APK doesn't build
instantaneously, right?
So if you want to get into that
world of quick experimentation,
you're in trouble.
It's not going to work.
This is what I'm basically
showing you today--
how to set that up--
because it's not that hard.
I'll touch really,
really quickly--
oh, I'm getting short on
time, so I'll skip on those.
Ask me questions after.
I'll be able to fill those in.
So, the basic live
publishing tools
that we have-- I use
IntelliJ with Node.js
and it runs a small
JavaScript program
that I can edit that will
actually push my geometry
into the viewer unit.
So what happens is, I have
my pipeline configured
on my phone, and it's getting
live data-- not from itself,
but from the internet.
So using Firebase that way--
if you've played with Firebase,
you know that its response
time is almost instantaneous--
so I can push my geometry
and push my edited shader
code straight into
Firebase, which broadcasts
to however many viewer
units are actively
subscribed to Firebase.
That's fairly interesting.
So you might be wondering how
to do real time reconfiguration.
This slide's just
here to show you
it's basically the same thing
we did at the initialization
stage.
You can just do
it between frames.
You can just create a new shader
and compile it and run it.
It also means--
well, we're going
to get to shaders at
this point because we're
talking about shaders.
Again, I want it to
be very, very clear
that vertex shaders, they run
a few times for each vertices
and then the pixel shader,
the fragment shader is
running in [INAUDIBLE], sorry.
What can we do with this?
So the geometry I've
been talking about
is iterative geometry.
So with OpenGL ES
3, you get a feature
where you can define your
shape and you can actually
make a ton of copies of it,
changing some attributes of it
as you go along.
So, this is the data structure--
I'm skipping a bit over
because I want to get
to the good bits faster.
So, this is me live editing
the geometry and IntelliJ.
So I hope I did that
fast when I recorded it.
Can see it's blinking.
Right.
So, what I'm doing is every
time I'm uncommenting a line,
I'm rerunning the
JavaScript program,
which is pushing new geometry
to Firebase, which is then
coming back to the
units-- it's actually
my physical unit next to
my laptop, in this case.
So we're just adding
new shapes as we go.
And we're just uncommenting
lines right here,
so what you can easily
do at that point,
start putting for loops in
there and creating cubes
and creating your own spaces.
That's a part we
won't get to today,
but you can see
the possibilities,
and you can start
experimenting very quickly.
So, then the other thing that we
can start doing is deformation.
So, I'm just
mentioning this to let
you know what's possible
with the shaders,
and which ways you can use
and abuse the pipeline.
So in this case, what we're
doing is that, it's an example.
The link is at the
bottom-- again,
I'm going to share
the slides later--
but this is an experiment
where you take a sphere,
you apply noise to the
distance of a vertex
to the center of
the sphere, and you
get a deformation like this.
You can come up with really,
really nice effects this way.
Like, that demo ends up being
like an actual exploding
ball of fire with
really nice effects,
and there's about 20 lines
of shader code in there.
And this kind of
stuff is for WebGL,
but it's easily
applicable to all
that I've shown you
today on Android.
Quickly, the fragment shaders.
So, texture mapping, you
probably know what that is.
You have a texture.
You're mapping it onto a shape.
So you have to think, oh,
who's doing the job of that?
It's the fragment shader.
Fragment shader is getting
all that texture data--
and since it's responsible
for painting the pixels--
it's the one that's
going to be looking up
those pixels in some cases
and taking them straight
from the bitmap and dropping
them into the right projected
space on those triangles.
So, where does that
become interesting?
So, you can abuse
the fragment shader
to do kind of
interesting things.
So, here I'm going
to show-- hopefully
quickly-- how to abuse
it to start rendering
geometric shapes
that have nothing
to do with the actual rendering
that we're going to be doing.
And the quick note I
wanted to show here
is that, while
I'm editing this--
so this is the ace editor
running in a web view,
pushing-- every time
I type a change,
it pushes the Firebase, comes
back to the viewer unit.
And what we were seeing
at the bottom here
was PID cat, logcat.
So we're seeing the PID cat
output of the compile errors
that I'm putting into
the web view right here.
The chrome pane.
So this allows you to play
around with the fragment shader
and then, in this
case, the FPS is
red to signal that
there's a compile error.
You can look at your logs.
You see which line, what
exactly you did wrong.
You start editing and you
fix it really quickly.
So that allows you to start
experimenting with shaders
in a way that you probably
would have never done
if you were just rebuilding
the APK every 10 minutes.
Hopefully, we should
see the results of this,
so I'm going to-- I'll just
let it run until it's done.
So now, all of a sudden, we
just have this flat, polka dot
pattern appearing here.
So what's going on?
So, it's really more of
a thought experiment,
but I just wanted to introduce
the audience to the idea
that there's something called
distance functions that
allow you to play
around with flat space.
So, in this case, we're
actually ignoring anything 3D.
We're just rendering
these circles
based on where we are
in the rendering pass,
because a fragment shader
knows where on screen it is.
So this allows you to do stuff
that's fairly interesting,
and this is an example of such.
Valve has a really
nice research paper
where they explain how to
use the texture system.
Instead of actually applying
and sticking a texture
onto a triangle,
what they do is they
take a high res texture
here-- like 4k by 4k.
They extract out of it a
distance field patch-- which
is another texture, really.
But they pass this to
your fragment shader,
and this is only basically
telling the shader, OK,
if you're at this point, you're
this far away from inside
or outside the letter.
And using that, they
basically managed
to implement something that
looks like vector graphics,
but is actually stored in a
64 by 64 bitmap-- or texture,
I should say.
So, this is just to introduce
you to the idea that you can--
once you start programming
your own pipeline,
you can do very fancy
things, and there's
a lot of people have done
a lot of fancy things,
and research papers like
these you can actually
look up on the internet
and they are very, very
self-explanatory.
You can apply all of this to
your programs in virtual space.
This is a quick explanation
of the full screen
fragment rendering trick.
I'm going to not explain
it too, too much.
But the idea here is that, if
you want to draw in flat space
and only use the
fragment shader,
you just need to put up
a full surface on screen.
Like, you put up two triangles
that fill up the whole view
screen, and you can
start playing around
with the fragment shader.
You might be saying,
well, what does that do?
What can I do that's kind
of interesting with that?
And, here, I'm going to
encourage you to go and look
at Shardertoy.
Shadertoy is a fragment
editing website.
Basically with the WebGL APIs,
they abuse fragment shaders
in an awesome way-- and
not just one awesome way.
If you go there, you'll
get the source code
for all these nice examples.
If you actually
visit this web page,
you'll see that all these
things are animated,
and you can just
learn from the best
and reuse that stuff
in your own examples.
Like, you can see that there's
actual worlds being built here.
You might be wondering,
how the hell can
you do geometry if you're
just drawing pixels?
How does that work?
They're not even putting
geometries in these examples.
It's two triangles
we're looking at.
You're going to have
to explore that.
Explore something called ray
marching, or come see me after.
I'll give you the links to
the papers, because we're
short on time and we
won't talk about that.
Actually over time.
Oh my God.
Am I good?
Well, kick me out
if I'm rambling.
All right, so, one of the
things I want to point out too
is they can do a search
for something called 2TC
in Shadertoy.
This is just to
impress everybody.
They organized what was
called a two tweet contest.
So the concept of
the two tweet contest
is, you have however many
characters fit in two tweets,
and that's how big your
shader can be-- text wise.
So all these shaders
fit within two tweets.
Whitespaces and
comments don't count.
And these are all,
again, animated.
If you just do that search
and go look that up.
And all this stuff is
online, and the shaders
are public, so you can learn
really interesting tricks.
And if you start thinking this
way, it's not actually so hard,
and I've done a few
proof of concepts
where you can create,
say, 3D fractals
and apply the VR
angle to it as well.
So when you do that, you end up
creating spaces that are really
interesting to explore.
And the major point here
is that that's not so
many lines of code.
Once you grok how
this stuff works,
you can be hyper
efficient and come up
with incredible effects.
And you don't have to have a
production crew next to you,
spending hundreds
of dollars an hour
to come up all
those nice assets.
You can do it yourself.
I'm almost done here.
I just wanted to-- actually, no.
We're skipping over those.
All right, VR challenges.
I'll take two minutes just to
overview the small problems
with the platform.
So, Cardboard--
that's awesome, right?
But you might see where
I'm going with that.
It's slightly problematic.
That can be a drawback.
It's not necessarily only
a drawback, but, you know.
The other thing too we have
to think about when you're
designing apps
with this, you only
have one clicker-- in some cases
you don't have one at all--
and you have to design for that.
That's slightly
problematic as well.
You can get creative and
start doing tilt-to-exit.
So, that's not a bad idea.
So, you can take examples
from the best apps out there
and start implementing
them on your own.
You have to start thinking
about head tracking.
It's a super rich
source of information.
You can do all sorts of
very interesting experiments
with that.
I've heard of a start up
that recently got finance
in Montreal, and all
they do is run analytics
to see where you're looking at
in the scene, where the head
tracking is going,
what's interesting,
and they're going to
resell that to advertisers.
There's fun stuff
you can do there.
Immersive audio-- if anybody
went to the HTC Vive try-out,
you know what I'm talking about.
It puts you into a
scene so much more.
The slight con
there is that it's
Cardboard we're talking about.
Not everybody's going
to take the time
to put on headphones
just for your app.
So you have to be a
pretty compelling app
to actually get somewhere.
Some pitfalls of the
platform-- so it's
food for thought for designing
your own apps, again, so some
of the things that don't work
all that great-- centering
and drift.
So you can try any
Cardboard app a long
while enough, especially
if you have a unit that's
strapped to your head, you're
going to notice that you start
off the game sitting this
way and at some point
you're like, wait a minute,
I'm sitting to the side.
I'm still looking
forward in the game.
What's going on?
And nobody seems to
think that maybe there
should be some sort
of re-center switch,
because, again, you're
sitting in your sofa.
Your range of motion is
basically-- well, it's not nil,
but it's very, very limited.
So what's the solution?
You suggest to people to
sit in a swivel chair?
I guess that works,
although kind of gets tricky
if you're alone
at home and, where
did I put that glass again?
Where's my coffee?
Standing up with
Cardboard, actually,
this is why I think it's
getting more clever in the way
that they put it, then the
way they have to hold it,
because when you're
standing up, you can't just
flail around and whack
people in the head.
So that's kind of interesting.
The problem there though
is that your reflex to move
is ingrained, like if
you're standing up,
I am sure that you're
going to drift.
For having tried it,
I can't help myself.
At some point I just take
it off and, oh, crap,
I'm three feet this way.
So, what else?
Guided experiences.
Since your audience is captive,
you can guide their experience.
So these are screenshots from
a lot of well-known things,
I think, but just to
go over them again.
So this is from Expeditions.
So, over-ear headphones,
no distractions.
So that's kind of interesting
if, in the case of Expeditions
for example, the
students wear headphones
so that they are not
distracted by the others
and follow instructions more.
And the instructor
has the microphone
that can feed into
everybody's head, basically.
You can guide your group.
You can point big arrows at--
let's say-- where to look at.
And what I've just
shown you, you
should see that
I've just given you
tools that allow you to publish
live to a huge group of people
anything, basically, you want.
So there's a pretty powerful
combination in there,
and, again, it's with tools that
don't require a big production
crew behind you to get
to somewhere interesting.
The advantages with Cardboard--
back to reality is really easy.
You don't have to strap
the thing off your head.
Scripting-- so like Windy Day
with the little mouse there,
everybody has
probably tried this.
It has scripted actions.
So it's being clever
in its use of,
OK the user's actually looking.
Now I can do something.
These are all
considerations that you
have to look into when
you're designing an app.
Another thing I'd
recommend is, there's
an actual design
pattern app from Google
that you should really look at.
That's very compelling and
it has some very clever ideas
of where you should go.
Almost done, two slides.
I'm a bit over, but nobody
hates me, so that's good.
Time for an upgrade.
So this is the point where
you go, OK, Cardboard's nice,
but I'd like to
make a proper set.
So what can you do?
So we have IonVR, our
sponsor at the barbecue.
I tried their unit, really nice.
The production units, I think,
should be very promising.
I'm really looking forward
to what they come up with.
Probably it's going to be soon.
The Oculus gear
is actually super
compelling for having tried it.
The big advantage here is that
they put the touchpad here
so you can interact
with your world.
So that's very much
a must, and something
very much lacking in Cardboard.
Like this default
sort of platform,
I want to interact
with the world.
The Homido is actually a
very good headset as well,
and they have an offer
for a Bluetooth remote
that can be used, so that
for users can be interesting.
Android Wear-- I'm not
sharing this with you yet,
but eventually on the
example code side,
there's going to be a
proof of concept I've
built with Android
Wear where, instead
of having to touch
your temple, you're
going to touch your watch.
And you can easily feed
events-- touch events--
into your Cardboard app
when the watch is hooked up.
It's actually super compelling.
It's got some
interesting use-- seem
like an interesting dynamics
because your hands are
trapped when you do this.
So you lose the
risk that the user
is going to flail that hot
cup of coffee into the dog
or whatever.
So those are thoughts.
Another thought here is that--
unless they've changed it
in recent months--
as far as I know,
if you sell physical
goods from an application,
nobody takes a cut.
That's true I believe from
Google Play and the Apple
store.
So that can always
be interesting
if you want your users to
support Cardboard first,
and if you want your users
to have the full experience
and you can actually
upsell them on it,
you can make money that way.
That could be interesting,
because we all
know selling apps
is not necessarily
an easy proposition sometimes.
So, that's one factor
you could consider,
which is what this slide
was actually about.
Sorry, I went ahead there.
All right, I'm done.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate you being here.